per tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video non stiamo facendo una roba
con la videocamera no e se succede lo
rotta bene credo si sia appena scassato
l'obiettivo fantastico
tutti ragazzi benvenuti ha visto video
sono fa vj entu dei siamo tornati su
happy with allora ragazzi la prima roba
che vedo la prima prima o slither io
snake o spiegami che cazzo di nome
stupido a plane a io voglio capire una
roba ragazzina perché fanno livelli di
slither io mi sono dato la risposta da
solo non l'ho capito veramente perché
fanno i livelli di slither iosue
pensabene in un mondo parallelo ragazzi
ci sono i livelli di happy meal su
slitte rio il contrario di un ictus jump
on the snake del jump on the finish line
grazie minchia come eguale adesso sicolo
finisca con la gamba vale non è un uomo
tradito è la migliore va bene ragazzi è
impossibile vi giuro è successo
ho lanciato il fuoco a caso va bene
mi spiegate perchè ha lanciato il porro
solista ma non importa va bene così poco
pro 4 e vabbè la madonna cos'è sta roba
santo iddio veramente ok ho guadagnato
un pene posso vincere adesso vi
offendete se se vado grazie
c'è qualcuno mi spiega come ho fatto a
perdere la testa vi prego
no
[Musica]
qui
beh
[Musica]
ragazzi io li adoro sti livelli non lo
so perché mi sto scherzando sono proprio
cagare a spruzzo come fai seguito
ma dai quanti problemi per finire un
livello stupido
niente ora è impossibile però si più
sexy così devo ammetterlo posso farti
una domanda non puoi arrivare
semplicemente al traguardo invece di
cercare a caso ok
scherzavo ragazzi non ho capito
seriamente cosa devo fare per farlo
non è che è toccato il traguardo va bene
va bene va bene va bene ok questi
livelli sempre più strani nella vita va
bene così parkour master 2.0 devo fare
io ma mi chiama manco mi alzo dal divano
io mai a gas veramente cos'è sta roba
saldi dio può fare il parkour ma tu sei
con chi stai parlando zio che una volta
sono sceso da un gradino mi sono slogato
una caviglia
l'importante è che la bce abbia una vita
felice poi vale come ha fatto a morire
prima che non mi ricordo ha così giorni
e va bene amica che piano piano qua
perfetto ce l'ho fatta ho superato il
punto di prima ragazzi è già qualcosa
ok solo una gamba perfetto ma no ho
fatto sei scemo
mica se semo rivo alla fine schiacciato
sul muro mi mettevo a ridere giuro world
file da un avatar
se una battaglia con le spade decente
però questa la morte più brutta della
storia della vita di è più il
bruttissimo inglobato non sa che nella
mia bici perfetto perfetto perfetto ma
non ha riso fatelo tutti lune può ora
che in genere su questi livelli non so
come sto l'offesa mi ha salvato la vita
non so come ragazzi ho fatto una cosa
incredibile no vabbè non c era gay un
genesi livelli faccio veramente cagare
non so come ho fatto a vincere
impossibile tecla xchallenge la
challenge degli orologi e la madonna che
figo protipo quando incontrò il bis ord
l'ho preso cos'è cos'è come ho fatto
aprendo non ci credo mai
sembra la scena quella di ritorno al
futuro ragazzi uguale
grande mi chiama un fenomeno è un
fenomeno veloce tirati su zio tirati su
dove standa cosa fa è scemo no ragazzi
devo ripartire perché non riesco a
tenermi poco ce la posso fare che non è
così difficile problema ok è la madonna
quanti sono io ho finito
ho avuto l'ansia perché sono caduto nel
vuoto fantastico rob swing v4 questo mi
sembra decente dal titolo mi chiedo è
diventata un acrobata edito da un
livello pre cece lite rione livelli
basta fatto è di una vita non è se
l'inter io è più che sono protetti e
mettere se l'iter io in tutti i livelli
non ha senso mela volete spiegare sta
roba che ancora non la capisco detto 324
non ho letto cosa ci ha scritto devo
imparare a leggere ragazzi è una specie
di quiz in tempo reali non ho manco
capitolo il quiz figuratevi fare la
dizione veloce devo aggrapparmi cosa
devo fare
mi fate arrivare alla fine per cortesia
che ciò l'ansia santo iddio ti è
piaciuto il massaggio è apparsa anche
una j mi onora e grazie frate lei tris
is dangerous o mio dio devo aver paura
visto a livello lo so già infatti devo
veramente schivare i pezzi del tetris me
la cavo in sti livelli ragazzi allo
scarso a tetris scuola normale
figuriamoci con linee più in su ma mi
tolgo la vedo bruttissima ma come ma se
mi aveva appena sfiorato ma cosa non
riesco neanche uscire di qua di un mio
perfetto bravo e ci sarà stupido ma
[ __ ] rega è impossibile
ragazze veramente il livello di e più
incasinato che io abbia mai fatto
ultimamente c'è dio mio
quanto è difficile perfetto
schieratissimo vai
e va beh ma mi chiami ventola sono
professori era sopra se titolo salto su
un pezzo del tetris che sta accadendo
poi ci ho ripensato di che stava facendo
una figura di merda rega non saltare non
qui no mi sono rotto le palle a ben del
sangue rei di save che se non ti
offendere ho fatto una domanda 3 igt che
suol dire io e l'inglese ragazzi sono
fantastiche non ho letto niente ma o
scassato un muro va bene non è un
problema perfetto e spero che col muro
non fosse di qualcuno questo muro sembra
più forte ho bisogno di un martello per
scacciarlo va bene dove lo trovo marche
sono ma per chi cazzo mai preso per thor
a ecco perfetto hai preso martello va
bene ma cosa devo fare
cliccare sul muro a non si scappa
perfetto ho preso un martello melo sono
messo nel pube e vado di penati e sui
muri e pensi scassano tutti è così zio
carico perché devo infilarmi nei pertugi
su cui è già difficile l'altro questi
umori sono fatti di carta pesta regga il
soffitto sta collassando devo tornare
indietro ma zio mi si sono staccate le
gambe riesco neanche più
ma cos'è sta roba eh vabbé vasai stronzo
ragazza collassando il soffitto
ok vi rendete conto che sono diventato
un pokémon e così a questo no dai
migliori nostro senza gambe rega vabbè
dai non importa sono arrivato tanto
avanti basta questo il 99 per cento
impossible iii gloria devo fare tipo ok
vai già sono arrivato qua sopra già un
traguardo arrivo
non ci posso credere 888 con ferdi quasi
un numero però le tabs on preview
cosiddetta un font jump to win
siri loading va beh non ci credo
veramente 9 aveva che figata che si lo
blocchi ma c'è anche series slide to
unlock perfetto orologio e vabbè è
facile così mica fammi vedere l'orologio
che gira con tanto di sasha grey
attaccata alle lancette facetime non va
facetime su calendario non va il
calendario non cazzo visto telefono
perfetto notte fa i compiti fatto parti
e sta enzo pare veramente ragazzi prova
a mettere il mio numero per vedere se se
mi chiamava non credo che funzioni e poi
ci provo volevi addosso convinto che non
funzioni questa roba ragazzi però nel
dubbio lasciano perdere messages mozart
va bene mail safari male al figlio si è
comunque più intelligente della city
quella vera quindi va benissimo 5 su 5
livello dell'anno ragazzi color
confusion che cazzo è un dio è va bene a
nel senso che quando ho capito che cosa
è successo
no vabbè bellissimo come mi sono salvato
effetto devo saltare tipo velocissimo
madonna che culo
non ci posso credere come ho fatto a
salvarmi tipo c'avevo metà corpo va bene
la caverna di cristallo cazzone frozen
contro speaker to play sipro stai calmo
dove devo andare
ma perché sono in una caverna con un
elicottero spie qualcuno voglia di
spiegarmi che cazzo ci faccio in una
caverna con un elicottero
qual è il senso di star a tutte ma come
faccio a leggere che manco sonda dritto
io fatti e non abbia capito che sto
dovevo fare prova bene fluffy bird
ragazzi chiudiamo con un livello decente
spero che sia dice vabbè se non altro è
almeno ingegnoso ahimé non si può finire
non come quello di prima perfetto un
camper che non posso toccare boca e
fermi già posso fare lo sento vai frate
non devo toccare i bordi perché sennò
salto in aria perfetto capito lei mi
chiama ve lo ricordate frati bird che
tragedia che era sono stupido vai vai
vai frate vai frate va il frate ma il
frate va il frate è così che conquisti
la [ __ ]
è così che conquisti la [ __ ] ai fratello
solfa vivo porca non ci voglio credere
66 mila like li voglio tutti dopo questi
voglio tutti allora ragazzi con quello
che mi sono cascate le cuffie come
concluso che l'episodio con questo
finale è piccolo cenno va però fatta a
vincere ero morto a metà livello va beh
spero che mi sia piaciuta ragazzi cosa
mi è piaciuto essere un commento è un mi
piace tanti mi piace portanti deve
esplodere il tasto stavolta io in tutto
questo ancora non ho trovato il
coperchio del mio telecomando prova bene
cosa insegna ricevuto solo un commento è
un mi piace anche a pagina di facebook e
cavani ridotto bene scrizione diavolo
prossimo video ragazzi